[Music]
this week i'm delighted to welcome back
the spectator's chairman anjanil he's
been closely following the pack that the
scottish greens have signed up with the
smp or another ploy for independence but
is it a good deal for the s p or the
greens or scotland
andrew welcome back to spectator tv good
to be back and great to see spectator tv
doing so well this is very weird because
we're reversing positions here but tell
us about tell us about what's going on
with the green party and the s p north
of the border because have they struck
some kind of faustian bargain well they
certainly struck some kind of deal it's
not a full-blooded coalition
uh but it's a semi-coalition and the
greens get uh
two positions in government now two in
nicola sturgeon's government two
positions specially created for them
one will be a minister for zero carbon
buildings active travel which i think
means walking
and tenants rights and they're going to
go for rent controls the other will be
the minister for green skills a circular
economy i'm not quite sure what that is
and biodiversity i mean
this is how you pick ministerial jobs by
just going into a dictionary and picking
out words and adding the titles and
they've been entirely created for these
two have never been in government before
um
i think it's it's all optics it's a bit
performative here from nicolas
sturgeon's point of view i think that um
she failed in the may scottish
parliament elections she did incredibly
well but she failed to get an overall
majority
but if she now brings the seven green
votes in
she can claim that she has a quote super
majority in parliament for a second
independence referendum which she hopes
she will win
now there's a bit of uh maneuvering here
because the fact is
that nicola sturgeon could always count
on the votes of the greens for a second
referendum anyway and i think it's
simply she's got very little red meat at
the moment to give her own supporters
and this is at least something come the
snp conference this month that she can
throw at them to say you know i've now
built in guaranteed a super majority for
a second rev referendum the greens get
their feet in government these two
characters get another 30 000 pounds a
year each
for their wonderful roles in zero carbon
buildings and circular economy
and um and i think that's probably the
second reason why there's something in
it i mean there's a lot of downsides
which we can come on to i think the
second a performative or optical reason
for nicola sturgeon is that cop 26 the
great big climate jamboree coming up in
glasgow in november
i mean that's a boris johnson show
uh nicholas sturgeon uh as the minister
of only a devolved parliament has felt a
bit left out she'll now be able to
mingle with the great and the good
saying i'm now in coalition with the
greens the greens are part of my
government that is how
much i'm uh i'm a greedy
myself and i think that will help us
strut the international stage a bit well
i didn't think it was funny though that
greta thundberg this sort of joan of arc
character for the green movement you
know she said that scotland is not a
world leader on climate change that
can't have been convenient for nicolas
sturgeon
it wasn't convenient for nicholas
sturgeon and it shows how the cybernets
uh these uh terribly pleasant people on
twitter and so on uh will turn on a six
months before per ms thundberg who said
something which actually isn't that
controversial uh you know scotland isn't
really a world leader and this is pretty
good at renewables but on all sorts of
other things it's still way behind she
says scotland isn't a world leader and
suddenly this international icon this
global icon is being duffed over as if
she was in sucky hole street on a
saturday night
um there's the pubs closed uh and
fighting broke out um and there were
terrible things being said about her so
it shows that you you can get their
support but the moment you say something
they don't like they're done on you like
a ton of bricks they're not
this will come as a surprise to you
they're they're not the nicest people
and andrew when it comes to the greens
you've written that they make the green
south of the border sound sensible by
comparison now you've talked a little
bit about the circular economy
and other things but what do they stand
for and how much more radical are they
well put it this way the the english
greens
are a lot more radical than the german
greens uh who are very grown-up greens
and they've been in government before
and they could well be in government in
germany again after the elections later
this month so the english greens are not
as grown up as the german greens who are
actually now a moderate center-left
green party
and the scottish greens are nowhere near
as moderate as the english greens
they're pretty much outliers in the
green spectrum and they uh they want to
abolish the royal family you know lots
of people want to do that that's not
particularly radical but they want to
take confiscate all their lands as well
they want a wealth tax and if the
scottish um parliament doesn't have
power for a wealth tax which probably
doesn't at the moment they say that
should be done by local authorities well
anybody who knows local authorities in
scotland
giving them a wealth tax will put the
fear of death
there
they are anti-car
they are
anti-above all anti-economic growth
they want rent controls and the one
thing that you know economists
really agree about anything but the one
thing that economists on the left and
the right agree about is how terrible
rent controls are uh yeah that isn't
just a milton friedman or the adam smith
institute uh paul krugman the left-wing
economist who writes for the new york
times nobel prize winner he said that
rent controls are a disaster everywhere
they've been introduced berlin stockholm
uh even at some extent in new york and
days gone by they lead to terrible
shortages of rental property but that's
what they want now nicholas sturgeon is
a canny politician
and she has not given them their wish
list
at all
and indeed she has basically ring-fenced
the economy from this anti-economic
growth uh faction and she's not agreed
that if you do more than one return
flight a year you pay an escalating rate
of tax for every other flight she's
not stupid she's not going to go down
that road either the scots like their
summer holidays in the sun
but it is a problem for her because she
has aligned herself in terms of public
ascension perception with a clear
anti-growth anti-capitalist anti-market
economy party i mean mr harvey the
co-head of the greens has said that he
wants capitalism must end he said not
that long ago how he intends to do that
we don't know and i think it's a problem
for nicola sturgeon as far as business
is concerned and foreign investment
which scotland needs a lot of or even
investment from england
as well because nicholas sturgeon was
already seen as not as business friendly
as uh alex salmond her predecessor alex
was was seen as being
yes a social democrat but when it came
to business in the economy he had been a
former economist at the royal bank of
scotland uh he knew what he was talking
about he was actually in favor of very
low rates of corporation tax uh which
was attractive to business nicola
sturgeon uh junked that she's just i
mean i remember interviewing alex simons
once up in uh just outside aberdeen in a
hotel that was owned by one of his big
supporters this was a businessman and he
just said alex simon he's going to be
great for business uh you know he really
understands how business operates
no one's saying that about nicholas
durgen and now she's in bed with the
greens who are clearly an anti-business
policy anti-investment in roads and
upgrading uh roads anti-economic
growth
oil and gas a huge issue still in
scotland 100 000 well-paid jobs
depending on it they are against further
development of oil and gas
the greens have said they are
responsible for the significant change
of direction in the scottish government
when it comes to oil and gas so when you
add all that up it it
reduces scotland's
attractiveness
as a place to do business and a place in
which you might consider investing
and could it also backfire on the greens
as you mentioned nicholas sturgeon
hasn't given them their most radical
demands or many demands at all and it
almost seems like a law of nature for
coalitions that the smaller party gets
eaten up
yes it does as uh nick clerk will tell
you
after his experience with david cameron
and george osborne i mean i think it
does have dangers for the greens and we
did we've already seen it um
at the weekend maybe just before the
weekend patrick harvey one of the two
leaders of the scottish greens uh
attacked the very idea of vaccine
passports
and what have we seen well we've seen
the
scottish government yesterday
effectively announce the introduction of
vaccine passports and
patrick harvey and his uh
co-government minister lorna slater the
other co-leader of the greens are the
two now in government they're just going
to have to suck that up and meanwhile
the green party
has issued a statement saying they're
very worried about vaccine passports so
it has
a lot of problems uh for them i think
there's also a huge issue i want to get
too parochial here but these things
matter in scotland is the upgrading of
the a9 road that's the road from perth
to inverness and the a96 which is the
road from aberdeen to inverness these
are dangerous roads at the moment
they're not all dual carriageway and
it is a very popular policy which the
snp have supported to
fully doom to make them fully duel
carriage
way roads make them safer make them
easier to drive on
it's not clear that the greens want to
go along with that indeed i'm pretty
sure they don't want to go along with it
so there's a plenty of opportunity i
think for some grit in the oyster here
but as you say it's all about
independence with nicolas sturgeon's got
this conference coming up in the autumn
can you give us a look ahead to what
that independence reigniting of that
debate will look like because she's been
relatively quiet in recent months
because of covid i guess
in pushing that cause
the line has been cindy that they don't
want to push independence or a second
referendum which is an essential first
stage towards the possibility of
independence until they've got on top of
covet now that's a problem for them
because we learned yesterday from the
world heritage world health organization
that
50 of the top 20 covert hotspots
in the world are now in europe now in
scotland
50
so
not quite clear that they're actually
getting on top of covert
but nevertheless she has her party
activists
uh that she has to feed this red meat
too
there's not a lot else she has to talk
about if you look at the record on
education or
in schools or health
or crime now where there's a problems
with the latest crime figures in
scotland or even in infrastructure i
mean other than the new bridge over new
bridge over the fourth there there's not
a lot of major infrastructure the the
main road between glasgow and edinburgh
which is the main
artery in central scotland is still
something that's now about 50 years out
of date uh there's no high-speed
railways in scotland there's no titanic
infrastructure other than the bridge
which closes in bad weather by the way
too so you want to make like two to
temik so she's not got a lot of red meat
to throw all that matters for them is
independence this with alliance with the
greens helps her get through that
she also thinks it's now a stronger
argument with boris johnson she can say
look i've got a super majority in the
hollywood uh
parliament i've got 72 out of 129
votes when i add in the greens for
independence or for a second referendum
so you can't deny that to me uh but i
think mr johnson will uh and i think
he'll say
look until there's a a clear indication
that the scots want a second referendum
and there isn't yet uh very
only i think about 35 percent wanted on
nicholas sturgeon's timetable i think
he'll just say no and there was a
significant development from the
scottish secretary of state
in the past days where he actually
firmed up on what the yardstick would be
for a second referendum which was
that the polls for a prolonged period of
time
need to show 60 percent or more of
scott's one-to-second referendum now
they're nowhere near that at the moment
he got criticized for saying that but
actually i think it was a shrewd move
because if the westminster government
does not give
some kind of criteria as to what would
trigger a second referendum
then nicholas sturgeon could rightly
argue that there was no democratic route
to independence
there was no the westminster government
should could just say no no no
no you can argue whether 60 percent is
high enough or too high that's one thing
but they've said a yardstick now which
means that there is a democratic route
to a second independence referendum if
it is the and user favorite phrase of
the scottish nationalist the settle will
of the scottish people that they want a
second referendum
very interesting andrew and while i've
got you here i know that you've been
following the situation in afghanistan
very closely um in all of your years of
doing journalism how big of a moment do
you think that the last month that we've
seen will be considered by history books
oh i think uh this is a watershed moment
i think it's huge it come about you know
it's been compared to previous historic
events uh in modern times but actually i
think it it it combines uh
all of them
it uh it combines the retreat from
saigon
in 1975
actually the retreat from saigon was
done in a rather more measured way
despite that helicopter famous
helicopter picture coming off the u.s
embassy
there was a much more measured retreat
because
the saigon government lasted for two
years uh after the americans had
effectively withdrawn it didn't all just
happen overnight despite that uh totemic
picture so i think it's as big as that
it has elements of farce and
embarrassment of the bay of pigs
invasion uh when the cia sponsored the
cube anti-communist cuban regional
rebellion in
invasion which ended in farce and total
victory for fidel castro secured his
position in power in fact
and of course the hostage situation in
tehran in 1980
and we know that there are still a
number of american citizens not just
allies of america a number of american
citizens who are still in afghanistan
including 32 students from california
now there is mr biden's next crisis
staring him in the face how does he get
these kids out what were they doing
there in the first place is another
matter but how does he get them out so i
think if you look at this uh
it has all the elements of the bay of
pigs saigon
and the tehran hostage crisis rolled
into one
and out of that humiliation and
embarrassment uh
and the the denigration of american
power and american standing in the world
comes major geopolitical
changes
which can only strengthen the position
of china
in places like pakistan as well as
afghanistan and of russia in the central
asian stands
the the the stands that used to be
soviet parts of the soviet empire and
you can even see an emboldening of iran
with russian and chinese support in the
middle east
as well so i think the geopolitical
ramifications of this uh embarrassment
and humiliation
have yet to unfold and i see that mr
biden has said i was just looking that
he said that
the war was now over the afghan war was
now over
that's the exact phrase the war in
afghanistan is now over well
the jihadists don't believe that
i think isis k the akani network
al-qaeda will all be pouring in there
again to use it as a base the jihadist
certainly don't believe that then i fear
that far from being over it's simply the
next phase of the war not it being over
and a more dangerous phase
angel thank you so much for joining us
on the show
[Music]
you